[Música]
porque en colombia los ciudadanos
acudieron a las urnas para renovar el
congreso y elegir a los candidatos
presidenciales de tres grandes
coaliciones políticas en la izquierda
está gustado petro en la derecha
hablamos de federico gutiérrez y en el
centro está sergio fajardo ellos
resultaron los ganadores de sus
respectivas consultas en los partidos el
pacto histórico que reúne al grueso de
la izquierda colombiana logró por el
momento 16 escaños en el senado y 25 en
la cámara de representantes vemos cómo
se va dibujando entonces este nuevo
congreso pero sin embargo el partido
liberal se encuentra en la primera
posición con 32 curules esto en la
cámara de representantes con los mismos
congresistas que el pacto histórico se
sitúa el partido conservador colombiano
y también el centro democrático el
partido del actual gobierno quedó con
sólo 15 puestos y también analistas
dicen que fue uno después de los grandes
perdedores de la noche el partido de
gobierno del presidente actual y bando
que para eso entonces van a ver para
analizar estos resultados saludamos a
camilo granada él es analista político
de comunicaciones gracias camilo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 por supuesto empiezo a
preguntándole cómo se pueden leer estos
resultados de cara a las presidenciales
del próximo 29 de mayo
trajo muy buenos días y dadas por la
invitación y dos grandes conclusiones en
la en las dos grandes resultados está
mencionando por un lado la desaparición
del centro de esa propuesta que se
pensaba que era la solución a la
polarización entre extremos de izquierda
de derecha que debería surgir a través
de la coalición centro esperanza pues no
tuvo los resultados esperados
y quedó consolidado otra vez una una
oposición de izquierda a derecha si se
quiere convencional en colombia eso en
cuanto a la perspectiva frente al
partido a las elecciones presidenciales
en cuanto al congreso usted lo señalaba
hay un avance muy hay un giro a la
izquierda importante avance de la
izquierda colombiana en en el congreso
sin embargo el papel lo que uno ve en el
congreso es que el congreso quedó muy
dividido también entre izquierda y
derecha y muy seguramente el partido
liberal que tuvo la mayor votación en la
cámara como usted lo señalaba
muy buena votación la tercera votación
en el senado podría ser el fiel de la
balanza para darle gobernabilidad al
próximo presidente bien sea de derecha o
bien de izquierda pero la gobernabilidad
en colombia va a quedar va a ser muy
difícil para el próximo presidente no
importa quién gane ahora cambio también
claramente en el pacto histórico se alzó
como el gran vencedor de toda esta
jornada electoral esto se trata de un
giro real de colombia digamos
tradicionalmente derecha ahora a la
izquierda
sí sí señor yo creo que claramente la el
éxito del pacto histórico de candidato
gustavo petro muestra un giro a la
izquierda
muy muy marcado en un país en el cual
colombia siempre había estado gobernado
entre el centro y la derecha
y la izquierda nunca había tenido una
opción tan clara de llegar al poder como
hoy
ahora también hablemos de otro fenómeno
de la jornada estamos hablando por
supuesto de francia márquez que no gano
pero que es si resultó la tercera más
votada en todas estas consultas
interpartidistas además fue tendencia en
las redes sociales en twitter cuál es su
importancia la importancia de la figura
de francia márquez
bueno no francia márquez es sin duda
alguna la revelación política de estas
elecciones
efectivamente consell o señalada fue la
tercera candidata más votada y superó
incluso al ganador del centro que sergio
fajardo en 20 años de votación y es muy
significativo porque es una mujer afro
colombiana la primera y por lo tanto esa
mezcla de ser mujer y afro colombiana
pues irrumpe por completo en la en la
política colombiana y segundo es una
mujer que nunca antes había hecho
política
electoral tercero es una mujer que viene
de la periferia de las zonas más pobres
de colombia de choco y que por lo tanto
es un es un voto de confianza muy
importante que ella tiene y el
reconocimiento de una serie de
y desigualdades y de marginalización es
que han existido para esos grupos
sociales e históricamente en colombia y
muy profundas entonces es una es una una
bocanada de aire fresco
el buen resultado de francia marc es
para para colombia sí señor también se
hablaba a camille y se especulaba que
gustado peto el petró pudiera he hecho
ayer realizar digamos el anuncio de que
francia marqués pudiera ser en su
fórmula vicepresidencial y no lo hizo
todavía hay esta posibilidad de que ella
sea la fórmula vicepresidencial de
gustavo petro o está totalmente
descartado
no yo creo que es muy difícil
descartarlo por completo pero también es
cierto que en la lógica
electoral
pues el
candidato gustavo petro va a buscar como
todos los candidatos una una una un
complemento del
compañero de fórmula vicepresidencial
que le ayude a sumar votos y a cerrar el
campo que le falta para llegar a la
mayoría absoluta sigue en ese sentido
volvemos a mirar el tema del partido
liberal que podría terminar siendo
determinante no solamente para la
victoria de la presidencia sino para
garantizarle a un evento al presidente
de petro la gobernabilidad en el
congreso ahora también camilo petro lo
decía ayer que como estuvieron las cosas
en la jornada electoral de ayer el
pudiera ganar en la primera vuelta del
próximo 29 de mayo por otro lado en los
otros candidatos están después manejando
alianzas dicen que quieren frenar
digamos la subida de gustavo petro que
tan difícil puede ser primero que petro
gane en la primera vuelta o que tan
fácil puede ser y también qué tan
difícil sería
si se unen estas dos coaliciones del
centro y la derecha poder ganar le ha
gustado petro por lo menos frenar esa
esa primera ganada en la vuelta en la
primera vuelta al 29 de mayo
va a ser muy difícil ganar en primera
vuelta pero hoy esa es la meta
efectivamente y ahí volvemos nuevamente
al tema de a quién a quién puede venir a
apoyar a qué
audiencias electorales puede seducir
gustavo petro de cara a la primera
vuelta y claramente pues el electorado
de centro y centroizquierda sería el
principal su principal objetivo y hay
una cosa que es importante raúl tener en
cuenta si me permite es que en las
consultas hubo un poco más de 10
millones de votos y para el congreso
hubo alrededor de 17 casi 18 millones de
votos hay 8 millones de colombianos que
participaron en las elecciones al
congreso pero no tomaron decisiones
frente a los principales candidatos
presidenciales entonces y uno esperaría
que para la primera vuelta como sucede
en el 2018 haya nuevamente
18 millones de votos poco más de pronto
de votantes en la primera vuelta
entonces nos queda todavía un enorme
paquete de d
ciudadanos que habiendo podido escoger a
petro en la consulta no lo hicieron
entonces serán ellos los que deciden si
van a apoyar a petro o no eso está por
decir sí por lo tanto la presidencial
está lejos de estar jugada y uno no
puede concluir por la gran victoria de
petró en estas consultas que es que
tiene garantizada la victoria en las
presidenciales claro que a mí como usted
lo dijo sos casi 8 millones de votos o
más de 8 millones de otros que no son
menos que pues ahí tendría que estar
repartidos en estas elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 29 mayo pues
todo está por verse entonces si bien es
cierto que gustavo petro fue él y su
partido y pues digamos su alianza el
pacto histórico ganó en estas elecciones
el día de guerras legislativas pues todo
también está por verse en las
presidenciales porque como usted lo dijo
son dos votaciones completamente
diferentes y hay mucha gente a lo mejor
que todavía no está clara por quién
votar para que sea el próximo presidente
de colombia camilo muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa feliz resto de mañana
raúl muchas gracias por la invitación
feliz día para toda la audiencia
integral